what's happening there reject nation so
apparently last night
some batman elite images came out
i was like ooh gotta wait till the
morning to cover this
and now here we are and i have chosen
heavy spoilers video to do today why
because he knows what he's talking about
and b
got an interview with him coming up i
don't know when
but it's shot already those take a while
to edit so keep a lookout for that when
they're up anywho
very excited for this i thought we
wouldn't hear anything about the batman
until like
closer to dc fandom but you know it's an
exciting time for the batman leaks let's
get into it
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy that calls her girl nightwing
because she's what my dick turns into
dick grayson i mean by that so yes we're
still a family
show and the batman is just under a year
away
but that doesn't mean that the marketing
for the film isn't in full effect
we have a whole host of new promo
interviews and posters that drop down
things like that and a lot more
we're going to be breaking it all down
in this video and pointing out some
wow there's
if you enjoyed the video then please
smash the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for a sweet
serving of justice
every single day without the way thank
you for clicking this
now let's get into our batman image
breakdown
riddle me this which fun and friendly
villain
looks like an absolute psychopath now
yes it's the riddler i know we all had a
bad 2020
but this guy has turned from a lovable
clown
into one of the most zodiac killers yeah
when the trailer for the film first
dropped a lot of people were shocked to
see that the riddler was heavily based
on descriptions of the zodiac killer
yeah and we now have a brand new
close-up of the character he looks more
like him
absolutely this image sent to me a
couple of weeks ago in black and white
whether this has been colorized by a fan
or not i don't know
but it looks absolutely incredible
warner bros have been clamping down on
leaks for a long time
hence why i didn't post anything about
it but i've been absolutely
dying to talk to everyone about this
image i love
yes of how like this movie is already
feeling like
seven feels like director matt reeves
has taken inspiration
from david fincher so much so to the
point that he even got the riddler
looking like the zodiac killer to a
certain extent i feel like this
is a fan color colorization even here it
kind of still looks like it's inspired
by hush or it's just an early stage of
the riddler that's more the impression
that i'm getting but i love the more
grounded realistic take on it for sure
oh my god paul down isn't gonna kill it
but i bet there's a big portion of the
audience that really hates the fact of
how different it looks now i know from
sources working on the film
that this will be how the character
looks for the majority of the movie
when the trailer first dropped many
theorized that he would be donning this
for the start of the film
however reeves is trying to keep things
as grounded as possible
so he won't be appearing in spandex or
really changing from this
from what i've been told vance also
theorized that there was duct tape
wrapped around his face but this image
clearly shows that he's wearing a mask
rather than being someone that would
have to remove
that's his eyebrows right i wonder who
the torturer hey
batman have you tried this guy ha ha
yeah
great great job let the channel uh
there's also a green question mark in
the middle of a target
and this just looks so raw it's like the
logo the metal band from the 90s
and i'm so hyped to see if this is used
in the movie on clues
now why i think it might not be is
because there was oh
it looks like a puzzle with the pieces
placed slightly wrongly together
that's terrible grammar but i am the
world's greatest detective
and if you look closely just look
closely
and you might actually see that yeah
these pieces all slot together to make a
green question mark see
that's why i'm the best breakdowns on
the net now the text
also reads to the batman my life has
been a cruel riddle
it's very puzzling and enigmatic and i
hope we get an origin
story where the character is bit by a
radioactive riddle
i'm really curious to know what this
means as there could be a number of
things taken from it
but we do know that in the film he will
be called edward nashlin
in the comics we of course know that
he's called edward
so perhaps the character was an orphan
and he's trying to find out who his real
parents are
this would mean that his life is
somewhat of a mystery a riddle
if you will and it could entail that he
discovers his true name is mystery
enigma
by the end of the film it really feels
like they're setting up edward or nash
nation his new name to actually be a
character with a very
personal motive a very personal vendetta
where
i can't think of too many times we've
gotten that personal with
i mean especially in live action it's
never been this personal before even in
the
if you look back to the trailer just the
voice that paul dano has for the
character
there is something in this guy that has
so much inner turmoil and
rage and he is letting it out on gotham
city and toying with batman and i love
that
yeah absolutely hell yeah next up are
several shots of the batman
and in the first one the dude looks
badass we can see some twilight shining
in that will make you completely forget
rob battenson was once in those vampire
movies and it perfectly
tell your reminders and such an
incredible
shot i'm guessing that this is in the
cave but even if it's just purely for
promotion
it definitely is ditching on the couch
in the shadows
we also have a follow-up one of batman
it perfectly sets the tone for what this
movie is gonna be
it looks dark and gritty as hell and
like it's been ripped straight out of
the pages of dc's black label collection
the tone yeah and i feel that it's very
very epic
we also have one that accompanied these
of batman holding a batarang
this is something i too got sent a
couple of weeks ago and it's been used
on hot wheels toyota
i will probably be popping up on a lot
of the promotional material
the batarang itself looks almost
identical to the logo that is being used
for the film
nice and as i always say batman has a
good understanding
when it comes to branding lastly out of
the batman
that's gonna become my phone wallpaper
in the next 15 seconds
looks incredible and it has the city of
gotham superimposed onto batman
with him looking over the top of it with
the moon behind him
this
but there are some cool details that you
might not have noticed like what
scraper that we can see in the middle is
actually the chicago tribune tower
why this is important is because
recently we actually got some behind the
scenes images of the new movie flying
fox man
who is jumping from it however viewers
look closely
that isn't actually flying fox man it's
really batman
i'm guessing that this is actually wayne
tower and that the character will be
using this as a base of operations to
look over the city
i love that because it's right in the
center like everything is like perfectly
aligned in the center of a frame you got
batman
if that is wayne tower and you got the
batmobile right there he's right in the
center
of gotham looking over the city from
here he will be able to jump from it
and glide to almost any location and
with it being central to the city it's
the perfect place for batman to operate
out of
this is a really cool poster and i can't
wait to hang it up in my room so i can
impress
all the girls that i always bring round
now speaking of girls
next is the catwoman who we can see
still wearing the balaclava mask with
the little ears pointing out of it
similar to the riddler i've been told
that she will remain in this get up for
the majority of the proceedings
and it'll only be later on in the movie
that things really start to change
now we do know that she is the daughter
of mob boss falcone
and in the comic that this is based upon
the long halloween the character
searches for the identity of her parents
she ends up coming face to face with the
batman in falcone's penthouse
this seems very similar to shots in the
trailer so i'm guessing that a similar
plot will play out here with her being
on the search for who her real dad is i
didn't know much about that her looking
for parrots and then there's all these
theories going around that edward
is also an orphan so it looks like that
this whole movie
if all that is true with the villains
you know that comes with the dna of
batman obviously if all that's true with
the villains
then all this is going to deal with
parental trauma
can't relate in this man's story just
going to be one big counseling session
by the end of the film where batman's
sitting down with all that let's talk
it's important to be vulnerable
however the pair did appear together at
the funeral so maybe she already knows
and is trying to bring her father down
this aesthetic has been seen in several
batman properties
such as the mystery of the batwoman so
potentially they brought across the plot
points from that
for this movie we also have quite a low
res one of her on a bike
which we of course know batman chases
her on in the movie
careful bruce looks like you're falling
you've someone actually said that this
stunt man might have fallen on purpose
and this could be why selena gets away
this shot might even be in the movie and
i might have been taking the mick out of
it for the last year
when really the stunt man was meant to
do it so yeah
this is me apologizing and holding
accountability for myself
if the guy was actually meant to do this
i'm sorry
anyway that's all the images that i
think leave somebody
contains several looks and posters for
the film on its back
the reason i said that the riddler one
might be fan made is because on this
calendar we can still see that it's
black and white
so shout outs to whoever changed it and
if you know the artists just tag them
below
i'll try and add them to the description
i'm so hyped for this film
and it's now less than a year away and i
i really
can't wait the movie will be releasing
on the 4th of march next year
and until then i'll of course be
bringing you all the big updates as they
drop
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts below on what you think about
the images
what plot points do you think they could
be hinting at a poster
let me know exactly what your feelings
are as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
during the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications drop a comment below with
your thoughts on the pictures
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
alright guys thank you so much thank you
heavy spoilers for putting that video
together breaking all those images down
catching all the deets i never would
have caught i guess the only thing is
that i'm a little questionable about
that that i'm complaining to
because i'm going to be able to see it
earlier i don't know march seems like a
weird time to release a movie
like maybe push it to may just because
yeah especially one that sounds cool
how big of an event is this yeah it's
gonna be like the pinnacle of any year
that it comes out in
i mean at least release it's like spring
break week yeah so that way you can uh
you know make sure everyone's watching
this get all those
co-eds off the beach and into the cinema
so happy we got these leaked images
already guys
and i can't wait for dc fandom so make
sure to subscribe and click that
notification bell because you best bet
we're going to be hustling that day with
cover ridge subscribe to heavy spoilers
keep a lookout for that interview last
but not least
sarah campbell i am officially
christening you the catwoman of the real
reader we got a lot of patrons with
roles and different characters they
correspond to well now it's your turn
partly because when i saw your name i
was like sarah campbell
selena kyle same initials actually not
k c make the same sound you see where
the connection's coming from and you're
a total
badass you travel the world you get in
and out of tight
spaces and whatnot i bet you could rob
me blind so sarah just wanted to send
you some love today
breaking the fourth wall hope you're
doing well and uh now the world's
opening back up i hope that you can feel
a little more free to get out there
yourself so
much love and hope you're doing well
okay was it good did i do did i do a
good
[Music]